foreign
let's go to Stephanie in Grand Rapids
Michigan where it's cold outside what's
up Stephanie
um not a whole lot how are you doing
good is it so cold
um it is pretty cold today but you know
what does that mean what does that mean
I think it's I mean it's probably like
30 or something I haven't even looked at
the weather to be honest nope nope it
did got to be 30. uh
Tennessee shuts off they just turn off
everything goes this is like this is
like defrosting for us but this is not
cold
it's awesome all right so what's up
Stephanie let's let's let's let's get to
Sullivan
yeah so
um I wanted to see if you could help me
with setting some boundaries for my
alcoholics mom
um I already have a pretty broken
relationship with her but I really only
see her around holidays so we are kind
of coming off of the holidays
um and even with those kind of like not
seen her so much it's still kind of
affects me if she's not sober or things
like that and I just wanted your
perspective on what to do
so when you when you say tell me about
how it affects you let's go let's start
there um
well like this past
anymore
um and she is in a state of mind I don't
know if it's alcohol or other drugs that
like she cannot come
um and so we do it without her and
that's it's fine I get to see my
brothers and my nieces
but it's still like the next day she'll
call and be like oh I just didn't feel
good yesterday can we reschedule and I'm
upset about it I don't know like so I
want to call out the front first part of
what you said
I think
when you
you all have planned enough events and I
and this is something I know firsthand
okay
not with my mom but with other people
that I care about
you plan something firsthand
and you make the plans everybody's in
there's probably some text messages
flying back and forth with some extra
exclamation points or some funny memes
and you do it every year and this is
what kids of of addicts this is who
people who love addicts are people who
struggle with addiction this is people
who are in relationship with people who
struggle with addiction
you allow yourself to believe this is
the year
and you get your hopes up a little bit
and then it the same thing happens and
then you said the magic word it's fine
we all get together and it's fine and
here's let me hear you say it's not
it's not Mom should be there she's not
and so then there's this air of
disappointment and you've probably over
the years gotten really good at taking
disappointment and burying it in the
backyard
and when you do that it grows and it
grows and it grows
and it kind of pulls the whole house
down right it just sinks everything and
then you feel crazy and then you get
pissed at her and it and for me it all
starts and ends with expectations
yeah and I think at this point I I do
I'm to the spot where I kind of expect
her to not be able to come I know but
you kind of hope she does right
yeah do you have little ones do you have
kids
no and that's part of the thing my
husband and I are starting to like
that's gonna be the next phase of our
life and so it's like that would change
things too and so
for me to and so I'm kind of to the spot
do I do I stop trying to plan things
with her because that feels really harsh
um it's not I have one brother who's
done that yeah and then I have another
brother who thinks that's wrong and yeah
um so I think you need a pretty robust
season of letter writing to her with
letters you're never gonna give her
okay here's what I'm really mad about
and maybe for the first time being
honest with yourself and going down that
rabbit hole I'm really like angry
and that anger may be back to when you
were a kid and
also I'm really really sad
like I miss you
like I want my mom
to come to Christmas and buy me a
present and be proud of me
and that's not Madness that's not crazy
that's not entitlement whatever that's
just like that's human a like I want my
mom to give me a Christmas present
and she won't even come because she's
too stoned or too high or too
embarrassed or too shameful or whatever
she's feeling
um I I think it's important to sit in
some of that and you might need to get a
counselor with that you might need to
write those and read them to your
husband and say you can't look at me and
I don't want to hit you like whatever
rules you need to come up with but
um or to get a group of women or go to a
group whatever it is but I think you
need to begin to grieve it because on
the other side of grief is reality
right this is the way this is I I have
managed this kind of thing in my life
with I plan things full-on
and there the plans I make are complete
and anyone is always welcome to be in
addition to those plans
so I set extra seats at my table and
this is metaphorical and and literal I
set extra seats at my table
because somebody coming
extra that I didn't plan for is a bonus
it's a gift
mm-hmm
it's not a the whole I don't build
something on everyone's got to be here
the whole thing Falls over
right and that at some level it's
protection but some of some of us just
be dealing with reality
and I think both of your brothers are
handling it on two opposite sides of the
spectrum and both of them are not are
not dealing with reality one of them is
scorched Earth dude that's your mom
right
and the other brother is like it's all
good dude it's all good it's like no she
is a uh person who is struggling to the
point that she's hurting people that she
reports to care about
and then you're there in the middle
right
let me let me give you this you are not
a bad daughter
before keeping yourself and your
marriage safe
you're not a bad daughter for thinking
if I have a baby right now I don't want
my mom around this baby and at the same
time I have to have my mom with me when
I have a baby
yeah both of those things yeah
it's definitely tough because it is such
a
we only see her so often and it just
yeah it's a repeated
most people in your situation spend a
ton of energy propping up a fantasy that
at one point the sinks hold things gonna
turn around it's going to be all good
and if I could just say the right thing
or plan the right thing or get the right
food or get the right meal get the right
gift then it will all be okay and this
isn't on you
yeah and I'm not quite in that spot
where I feel like I'm trying to get it
all perfect so that we can be together
and like pretend that we're a family
because even when she's there it it
doesn't feel like we're a family like
it's obviously broken we all know it's
broken we're not pretending there's an
elephant in the room it's just
I don't even enjoy that like right like
being it's
and that's I think what I'm struggling
with is like it's hard to be around her
even when she's sober because then it's
still
it's like our relationship I don't know
that's I think what I'm struggling with
is like is our relationship even
something that
I can spend time around her Maybe not
maybe not right now
okay and maybe she's making some choices
right now where she's choosing to not be
in a relationship with you that's
probably a better way to look at it
and to to truly get there
you've got to come up with here's what I
deserve in relationships here's what I
give in relationships here's what I need
and if you're the child of an alcoholic
you've probably been spending your whole
life trying to run around and solve what
somebody else needs
and you tend to bury your needs because
there's no value to them right who cares
what my needs are I've got my life is
spent meeting somebody else's needs and
maybe for the first time you start to
ask yourself here's what I need
and if she chooses to not meet those
needs
and she's choosing to not be in
relationship with you and then you got
to deal with that because that hurts
but that's the path towards owning
reality this is this is I gotta choose I
gotta choose reality
yeah
and maybe some of the choices of
choosing reality after like what I do
now maybe I'm gonna get a couple of
older women in my local community that
are friends of friends or a buddy of
mine her mom or some people at my church
if you're a church goer and I'm gonna
start making connections because I need
a wise voices in my life right I need
older women in my life who have been
where I'm headed
um and that's just not gonna be from my
mom
yeah and that hurts so bad I know
yeah
Stephanie it sounds like you're there
what's the hold up
um
I
I think it's just the
I'm sick of going through the same
things over and over again and like
having the same conversations with my
brothers and just like feel like we get
nowhere like okay so what if you stopped
then how do you like when if I said no
more calling your brothers
no more calling your mom that season's
over from this point before you're gonna
do Thanksgiving and Christmas elsewhere
you and your husband just gonna go do
your own thing you're gonna make it up
as you go you're gonna go up to Traverse
City and y'all just gonna have a fun
weekend and that's going to be Christmas
that's gonna be Thanksgiving how do you
feel
thinking through that
better the times that I don't have to
try to plan things
with her like so what's holding you back
from making that move
because I have people that tell me that
that's like
um I do have a brother that's a pastor
and so he also looks at that as like
that's not what Jesus would do right
she's broken she's has this mental
illness she's not strong enough me not
reaching out to her hurts her a lot and
I'm like but I'm in the back of my head
I'm like that's the bed she made not me
so
I go through that thought a lot of like
I'm hurting her but it's not my fault
um is the
things you've done up till now helping
no
and so there's this idea that I'm just
an endless bottomless pit of I just keep
showing up I just keep showing up and
that is not about helping this situation
that's about you feeling better that's
about your brother feeling better
right yeah because yeah if you want to
if you want to get theological for a
second Jesus showed up man to people on
the margins that's where I spent my
whole life is with sitting with people
on the margin instead everyone else says
you're not lovable for whatever reason I
believe in that and he also said there's
a moment when you dust your sandals off
and you head to the next town
when your help or support is not welcome
here
and that's a fine line I get that
and
that's why I'm saying one of your
brothers who just cut your mom off I
mean I I couldn't do that some people
could I could do that
but it might be that I'm gonna send a
letter once a month so that my mother
never know never forgets that I love her
and then I'm thinking about her
I'm not in a place where I can call
because calls always devolve into guilt
trips and why didn't you do this and
then I get sick to my stomach and I
throw up and it brings up old stuff so
that's not a healthy move for me
it's not because I'm a coward or weak or
a bad daughter it's because it's just
it's it's a it's a very very toxic it's
not smart
but I will write a letter
every month reminding my mom how much I
love her I'm thinking about her and I
care about you that's it
I do like that idea I think that's very
true but all that starts from what do I
actually need it may be part of what you
need Stephanie is I need a relationship
with my mom in some shape form or
fashion
I also need to not get sucked into these
two hour Vortex phone calls where I hang
up feeling like the worst human has ever
lived
yeah because my mom can be a vampire
okay so now I've got to come up with a
solution between I can't just abandon my
mom
and I can't continue engaging in our
relationship the way we have so I've got
to do something different
and maybe it's I don't um text Mom I
don't I'm not gonna return text anymore
we're just going to communicate via
letter
and if you have if you have an emergency
please reach out
um
or I will only respond to Mom's text 48
hours after I get it unless it's an
emergency
and that gives me time to process it and
feel it and then I'm not just responding
out of emotion you see what I'm saying
but this is you here here's the magic
word be curious about it don't rush to
say I'm the worst ever I hate all of it
I'd be curious about it whoa my mom just
sent me a text and it really got me all
fired up what is it about this text that
is sending me down a rabbit hole
does that make sense and you're gonna
begin to learn a lot about yourself
yeah how long is your mom's alcoholism
as she struggled
uh my whole life okay yeah
yeah have you gone to see somebody
um I have yeah and
um my parents got divorced when I was
like nine and that's when I like went to
Al-Anon and got some help and my dad's
gone through a ton of therapy as well
and so
it's definitely something that we've
come together I'm like be like my dad's
side of the family like it's a big
conversation we we talk it through and
are healthy and cool in our own ways but
yeah my I don't have like a memory of a
sober mom I mean like yeah I
light-heartedly joke that my stepmom is
like my mom but um
it's
yeah it's still but has she served that
role
yeah she has okay maybe you need to
grieve that too and celebrate it at the
same time
yeah I think you're right because that
was supposed to be your mom and thank
God somebody else stepped in to fill
that Gap right yeah that was a huge
blessing like it's a both end right
that's tough it's tough tough tough to
both hands
um yeah I I think you're right right
there I think you're right right there
um
I just want to give you permission to
put on your oxygen mask first as you
know the little cliche is and that's
going to look different for you in
different seasons and there may be a
season
when you feel strong and robust and I'm
wading into this stuff Mom I'm dragging
you by your pigtails we're going to AAA
I'm not having you may have a season
like that and there may be a season
where I gotta get some space and
separate and I gotta make sure I'm whole
and well and okay
um so that I can do the hard work of
heading back in and again you brought it
up so to get theological for a minute
Jesus continually retreated
to recharge
right to get prayer and quiet time
and in fact he lamented I don't have a
place to rest man I need to catch up but
I can always get dragged back into this
stuff there comes a moment when I gotta
step back and say what do I need to be
whole and well right now so that I can
love as best as I can moving forward
um
I would say given all things your your
mom won the lottery with you as a
daughter
you're a pretty amazing woman Stephanie
and um I appreciate your call thank you
so so so much